for today's classic interview we're
going back to a true classic i
interviewed bill Tatro back in February
of 2015 and at the time bill didn't
believe the Obama jobs numbers that were
coming out of the bureau of labor
statistics that's something that Donald
Trump had in common with him until the
bureau of labor statistics started
reporting on Trump's job creation and I
think that as you watch this interview
and listen to this interview you will be
reminded of the acute absurdity of what
we are hearing now from the Trump
administration about how we can
obviously trust the jobs numbers from
the same organization now that Trump is
president numbers and an organization
that we simply could not trust when the
President of the United States was
Barack Obama let's get to my interview
with Bill Tatro from 2015 i'm joined
today by bill Tatro who's a teacher talk
show host author lecturer and columnist
at townhall.com bill i was recently
reading one of the articles on your
website and I I'm kind of confused by it
so a good place I think might be for you
to explain exactly what your position is
on the kind of modern economy of today
and on President Obama in this article
you do point out some of the positive
things that we're seeing in the economy
but it seems like you hesitate to say
that this is truly a sign of good things
but maybe my read of it is just off talk
to us about that well baby one of the
problems that you've got with this well
I should say any administration but it
seems to be more prevalent with the
current one is that they've taken the
old adage of the question that was asked
to the government official what's 2+2
and he said what do you need it to be
and the problem is that if we go back
let's go back six years when mr. Obama
first came in the bureau of labor
statistics uses when they give out the
jobs report and we'll get it this friday
they give what they call the birth death
and the birth death is the number of
jobs that were created that month by new
businesses that were birthed number of
jobs that were lost by the businesses
that were
that died the deaths and that was and
then you net them together historically
with Clinton the bushes etc it was you
know plus or minus ten fifteen thousand
either way and then after a year it
would be corrected well as we got in
deeper and deeper into the Obama
administration they would find that it
was plus 125 thousand jobs plus 150
thousand jobs these were an actual jobs
this was just assumptions that were made
by somebody that they thought that would
be it and so every time when you hear
that last time we got 300,000 jobs you
have to look at birth death after 12
months it's corrected and it's put on
the back pages so the misinformation
that's put forward that as we look at
the unemployment rate five point six
percent but that's discounting millions
of people out of the participation pool
okay bye hold on a second okay there's a
lot there there's a lot there where is
your contention that unemployment is
being measured differently today than it
was under other presidents oh absolutely
absolutely you're looking at people who
if I go out if I'm unemployed if I'm a
chemist who can't get a job and all of a
sudden I'm oh my like neighbors wand and
get twenty dollars to do it i'm now not
unemployed no that's not true that it
what if you go that that that's simply
untrue bill and i think that most of our
audience after hearing me talk about
this for a long time knows that if you
are go out and mow your neighbors lawn
for twenty bucks that has no impact
whatsoever on whether the government
considers you unemployed or not because
if i lose a job and I file for
unemployment it doesn't matter whether I
go and collect those twenty bucks or not
I'm considered unemployed and and that
there is that's just a factually untrue
statement I don't know where you came up
with that well I disagree all right I
mean then we we have but you disagree
but it's not a matter of opinion that's
not how the bureau of labor statistics
measures an unemployed person we have to
be up front with the audience here well
I understand that so what you're saying
is that the the number of people who are
not part of the participation pool and
if there are you would then say that
number of people in the in the
participation pool is accurate know what
I would say is that we are measuring
unemployment if we look at the youth
three and the u6 in the exact same way
today that we have done all the way back
to Ronald Reagan and there is absolutely
no difference in the gap between the you
three and the u6 which includes as you
say discouraged workers those who are
underemployed etc there is no difference
in the space between the you three and
the u6 today as there was under Ronald
Reagan under george HW bush clinton w
bush etc the idea that today the numbers
are particularly deceptive because we're
not considering discouraged workers and
people no longer looking for work is
flat-out false we have the data we I
disagree and that's that I totally
disagree but so presently what data do
you have from the bureau of labor
statistics that tells us that the u6 now
relative to the u3 is particularly bad
compared to Ronald Reagan I mean it just
that's not the data that exists then you
are then your contention is and it had
my contention it's just the BLS data
that the participation pool is is
accurate what I'm saying is that today
if we talk about the u3 compared to the
u3 under Reagan or bush or whoever is
measured the same way but if we want to
talk about the u6 it's also measured the
same way the problem is that many people
today who want to disparage President
Obama's economy say that he is
presenting the u3 number as if it were
the u6 and that's just simply not the
case I don't think he's presenting you
three is a use six I think that this
this administration gives miss
information but the data is from the BLS
and they've been presenting it in the
same way since Reagan so what when you
say that they give misinformation what
does that mean well if you simply take
away the participation pool and you take
and you you
to reduce a participation pool yuvan
effect reduced your divisor why don't we
just go to four percent based upon what
you're saying we will get the four
percent unemployment as president has
said very quickly now we're not even
discussing the quality of the job we're
not even discussing if it's the majority
is in bartenders and I ok but bill now
you're moving the goalposts because
let's let's have the conversation about
wages and job quality I'm glad to have
that conversation I have that
conversation with economist all the time
but that's a different issue than to say
that right now because of discouraged
workers we have a far worse situation
than we did under Ronald Reagan six
percent unemployment for example that's
just not supported by the data now I
would I would grant you that wages are
absolutely lagging jobs in this recovery
that very often happens we've finally
seen some uptick in wages over the last
year although not last month but do you
realize that these are two separate
issues oh absolutely there's no there's
no uh you know I'm glad that we can come
together on something and that the that
the the wages are lagging um but I just
in your discussion of the participation
pool as I just I i I'm sorry I'm not on
that page yeah but the problem i'm
having conceptually with this bill and i
hope this is clear to the audience is
it's great that you and i can come
together like we said on the issue with
wages but the problem is you're saying
it almost as if we just have different
opinions but the data from the BLS
reflects what i said with regard to the
unemployment rate and the data from the
BLS reflects what you and i happen to
agree on with regard to wages but i
think we're getting a confusion between
what the data says and what an opinion
is right that you but those aren't the
same thing data an opinion are two
different things yes i will break
through that i will absolutely grant you
that do you believe that over the next
four years we may see at some kind of a
slow down or
correction when it comes to the job
growth numbers that we've been seeing as
well as the stock market growth that
we've been seeing and if so do you think
it will depend on who the next president
is or do you believe that we're simply
coming up on a correction to the economy
regardless of who is the next president
well that's very interesting question is
because you're looking at correction and
you're saying in the job growth
correction in in the market I have been
one that has been saying all along that
this market ultimately will have a major
collapse and I believe that much like
the Japanese market did back in the
early 90s when i went from 40,000 down
to less than 10,000 much as 75 percent
collapse i think the same thing will
happen here the jobs i think we're
already seeing it David I mean you're
looking at the amount of pink slips that
are being given out in the oil patch
you're seeing now just most recently the
announcement today of staples and and
what is it home depot or a job depot or
whatever and the combination there
hundreds of thousand people thousands of
businesses or thousands of stores will
be closed and there will be a lot of
people laid off yeah but again bill I
think that that's when we look at
anecdotal instances of retail job
slowdowns that does not necessarily tell
us something broadly about the economy
because in part retail is suffering
because of the development of technology
that makes it so people don't
necessarily rely on those retail stores
but the job growth continues we've had
record consecutive month after month job
growth dating back something like a
decade don't you think you know it seems
like you just don't believe the data no
I don't believe the data I mean let's
let's start we should have started from
that point do you don't believe the data
from the BLS under other presidents or
did you always think that it was
untrustworthy no I felt that it has got
an aggressively I mean you can go back
to George Washington and you can see
that information provided by various
presidents sometimes you have to look at
it with a jaundiced eye but again we're
talking not about information concocted
by press
we're talking about an organization that
has measured economic indicators in the
same way for decades so I think it's a
moot comparison to say hey Washington
made up some stuff well you I think
you're naively thinking that any of
these organizations are politically
neutral isolated you would say so so
your position like an the Federal
Reserve would be well it's not a
political organization it's not under
the government so it had again I'm not
talking about the Federal Reserve I
don't talk about the BLS I understand
that but I'm just saying that I believe
that the BLS puts numbers and as I said
two plus do what does it need what does
it need to be so you're saying that the
BLS simply does what the president
suggests i am saying if we go that
bluntly yes all right well i would love
to see some evidence of that i'm
guessing you don't have it today and it
coincides with us being out of time but
i would love to have you back I think
it's great bill that at least we agreed
on the fact that wage stagnation is a
serious issue we probably would disagree
as to what's causing it but at least we
agreed on that right well you know David
every long journey is that Jenny say
starts with one step and I think we got
at least one step today we have check
out bill Tatro on townhall.com thanks
for being on Dyl thank you David